what's going on guys
Peter Combofiend roses here to point out
some of the more prominent changes to
cami and Ultra Street Fighter 4 she was
already a strong character in 80 2012 so
the changes made we're more sort of
balance her out while still helping her
routine for fun features without further
ado let's get into some of her changes
cami was able to stun characters pretty
quickly in AE 2012 as a result her stun
output on some of her stronger combo
attacks has been slightly reduced the
tax specifically called out on her close
standing heart punch and her crouching
heavy punch which have been reduced by
30 and 50 stun respectively in addition
to camis strong ground game for tennis
strike allowed her to pressure ponens in
ways that most characters just had no
answer for additionally it could be done
high up in the air with cami remaining
advantageous when the attack was hit or
blocked this has since been changed so
timing players will have to use the
correct height when using this move or
face being punished due to the overall
high reward and low risk of camis cannon
spiked the attack has been adjusted to
make it slightly more disadvantageous
when the opponent blocks the attack and
she tries to focus councilmen - forward
this means cami players will have to
exercise greater caution when using this
attack or face proper punishment from
her opponent
although cabin is considered strong when
she gets in County players remarked that
it was sometimes difficult to get in and
were requesting new ways to help them do
so to address this cami can now cancel
her rule again combo into a cannon
strike
this should provide Cammy players a
quick way to close the distance to get
her into striking distance that much
faster regardless of whether camis
driver drives smash her hitting his full
animation form or not didn't really
matter as a damage difference was less
than 100 as you could combo into the non
animation version quite easily that
difference was even less noticeable this
has since been adjusted with the last
hit now doing 40 damage less than it did
in AE 2012
cami is still strong at Ultra Street
Fighter 4 although she has to work a
little bit more than she did in 8020
whoa and be played a little more
carefully than before she still has the
ability to steam off her opponents when
she gets the momentum going with the
addition of the chemistry council from
the hooligan combo Hemi players will
highly get more ways to mix up and scare
their opponents